police in Turkey suspect a Syrian woman
planted the bomb that went off in
Istanbul on Sunday they say she was
trained by Kurdish militants the woman
is one of more than 40 people who have
been detained over the attack the band
Kurdistan Workers Party or pkk has
denied any role in the blast at least
six people were killed and several dozen
in injured when the explosion ripped
through a crowded pedestrian street in
near tuxim Square
police raid a home in Istanbul following
Sunday's Bomb Blast
inside a suspect is arrested
turkey's interior Ministry claims this
person said to be a Syrian woman with
links to Kurdish militants was
responsible for planting the device
dozens more people are sent to have been
detained
the attack hit this busy shopping street
causing panic across the city as people
ran for their lives
I was talking on the phone all of a
sudden there was an explosion it was
pretty loud I looked out the window and
saw people running it's very sad because
some people just came here to uh to have
fun to enjoy to have a vacation they
went to the shop to buy something and
they didn't know that they will be it
will be their last day
I don't feel safe here anymore I'm
afraid it will be more bombings if I
ever have kids I don't want them to go
through something like this
I hope it will not happen again and they
managed to prevent such attacks
condolences have been paid from across
the world
but turkey has rejected those from the
United States it accuses Washington of
supporting the band Kurdistan Workers
Party or pkk which it claims is behind
the attack
the insincerity of our so-called allies
who officially sent the terrorists money
from their own senates
is evident
head on that
while the political fights continue
Istanbul cleans up the mess as the most
deadly attack in five years leaves this
city on edge
our correspondent Julia Hahn is in
Istanbul and earlier she told me more
about the police investigation
well Turkish police have surprisingly
quickly identified and detained a main
suspect less than 24 hours after the
deadly attack a Syrian woman is believed
to have planted the bomb on istikal
Avenue here in central Istanbul
according to the police she received
training by the Kurdistan Workers Party
or pkk and its Syrian Affiliates and
entered turkey from northern Syria 46
other people were also detained in
connection with the attack police say
they went through the footage of more
than a thousand security cameras here in
Istanbul in order to be able to make
these investigations and arrests now the
Turkish government blames the Kurdish
militant pkk which is listed as a
terrorist organization by Ankara but
also by the European Union the Us and
other Western countries interestingly
the pkk itself published a statement
denying any involvement in this attack
so did another Kurdish let group The SDF
in Syria now that certainly raises some
questions but the means for us
journalists here in Turkey for anyone
basically to independently verify the
various claims coming from different
sides is uh very limited very difficult
here the government strictly controls
the flow of information yesterday
immediately after the blast they imposed
a new span to what they say in order to
uh avoid Panic spreading among the
population today they're widely sharing
the images of the main suspect and her
arrest but right now this is the main
source of information we have uh talk us
briefly through the reaction to this
most serious attack in five years
well there is of course a great sense of
sadness among Istanbul residents I've
seen many people uh paying a visit to
the site of the blast today laying down
flowers I've seen people crying and then
of course there is the realization among
many of us living here in Istanbul that
this blast could have hit any of us just
because istikal Avenue is such a central
place it's very popular with locals and
tourists alike and many people were
there on a Sunday when shops and
restaurants were open to enjoy their
free time and then of course this
explosion this blast brings back very
painful memories for people in Turkey of
a series of bombings and explosions
between the years of 2015 to 2017 which
Nationwide killed several hundred people
some of the attacks were blamed on the
so-called Islamic State group others
were blamed on Kurdish militants and and
that is what many people told me today
that they are afraid something like this
might be happening again
Juliana corresponded in Istanbul there
thank you very much Julian